three words that could help put
Americans back to work
made in America Vermont senator Bernie
Sanders targeted the Smithsonian gift
shops to sell more made in America
products in to shore up America's
manufacturing base and fight
unemployment senator Bernie Sanders
called the Smithsonian's top officials
into his office in the gift shop we
should not be selling statues of the
founding fathers of this country have
the made in China and it's Adam and
that's well received among shoppers it's
a good idea American citizen I think we
should do more to support America
because then people here will have jobs
they can see the label that says Made in
China and they see it under statue of
the president and think something's
wrong here two hats made in America made
in China one of the prices nineteen
ninety five and ten ninety five so this
is almost half the price but it's made
in China yes something tells me that
this demand for that had at ten dollars
or they wouldn't be selling it so people
are obviously choosing to buy stuff from
China because it's cheaper Sanders not
only wants to keep American jobs here
but he expects his plan would create
more manufacturing jobs I hope in fact
all of course the board we begin to
focused on rebuilding our manufacturing
sector so that we create millions of
jobs in products made in the United
States Oh Sean you can pass lots of laws
to create jobs you could pass a law
saying we can no longer use computers
you can pass a law saying no more use of
heavy earth-moving equipment we should
all use spoons from now on every visitor
the Smithsonian will have to pay double
for the price of a baseball cap perhaps
they might buy less from the Syst
Sounion gift shop and then the retail
workers in the gift shop might have
fewer hours to work there the sorts of
unseen consequences the Mr Sanders
perhaps isn't thinking about or doesn't
care about the Smithsonian quickly caved
to Sanders demands after the meeting
with senator Sanders a new promise from
the Smithsonian we
agree that we would make more effort to
sell made-in-america products in our
gift shops state-directed industrial
policy is not the way forward allow
American businesses to do what they do
best allow them to create the new sorts
of industries the creative industries
the service industries that are that we
do best and that is by removing
regulations lowering the corporate tax
rate those sorts of things for Sanders
this isn't just about economics it's
about national pride of Museum owned by
the people of America a museum which
talks about our own history cannot even
have products manufactured in the United
States by American workers we've got
some very very serious problems why is
it embarrassing that we no longer
manufactured trinkets here it's not
embarrassing to me
that we've got better things to do with
our human resources we still manufacture
plenty of stuff in America it's just not
the stuff you see on the gift shop
shelves aircraft heavy equipment
semiconductors does he really want to
regress us back to the days where
American manufacturing sector no longer
makes aircraft it makes snow domes and
baseball caps